someone say jewels the Queen's jewels
the Queen's jewels so we've gone balls
and crown jewels essentially so
imaginative guys okay
cannabis meet Harley Davidson balls
lawyers the crew Queen's jewels and
lovely Kong the Queen's jewels they are
called the crown jewels but now the
Queen's jewels ladies and gentlemen I'm
gonna do something fun for you now but
to do that I need a good old buddy of
mine please put your together welcome
all the way from Australia mr. Jared
[Music]
Jared and I gonna do something a little
thing called a freestyle rap that is a
rap made up on the spot based in Italian
those suggestions it will not be
anywhere near as atrociously bad as
you're expecting it to be it's five of
you seem unconvinced that's fine
Jared you want to lay down lay down some
back in and Willow will do this oh [ __ ]
don't want to break this yeah I'm aware
this is tremendously white and I
apologize
it's gonna be fun oh yes chicken crispy
smoked up one one okay can be risky and
one thing be aware of all that catches
up with you quickly cause it's an Ed the
boy also next yes I always fall on my
Russian movement mystical walls and the
bear is Maximus
you know what golden so damn fast beside
small there was a little baby but as I
hate through puberty you went crazy it
was so low hanging on the asphalt I was
like that's a handful
testicles we're not ever see a lawyer
like skills piano because we've got that
addition mastery yes I'm sure but if I'm
in court with the judge on the bench
that'd be bad sucked blood yeah
kill drop the pretense unhinge I'm
working with my client let me know who's
so damn violent how the French Empire
the colonies to pull out the jewels from
overseas they went to India took a big
sapphire they were like this jewel one
day aspires to be in the crown on an old
lady's head in about five years will
crikey she'll be dead Cooper when she
he's like you can read it's the pitch
off the back but in this place the
bridge because it's being built off so
that's not making me a Miss soften it
and that way it means is so fast if you
ride motorcycles we're home and take
care
[Applause]